-Welcome back.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
-First of all, congratulations.
You have a baby on the way.
-Yes, yes, yes.
-Very exciting.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes. Procreation is under way.
-It is under way.
-Yeah.
-And you were actually --
You presented at the Tonys
on Sunday night.
-I did. I did.
-And how was that?
How was that experience?
-You know, it was -- it was --
It was fun until I had to do
the actual job of presenting.
Because I was --
I was sat backstage.
And they called me.
And I stood up.
And I went to go
and do my little spiel,
read the monitor and stuff,
and this happens to me
sometimes.
Like, I'm still pretty active
when I take my SoulCycle class
and everything.
But occasionally, I'll stand up
and get profoundly winded.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-And this was one of
those occasions.
And I was like, "Oh, my God.
I don't have access to oxygen."
[ Laughter ]
"Like, at all.
And I'm supposed to be reading
in front of thousands of people.
In fact, millions of people."
So, yeah, I eventually, like,
recovered and found my breath.
But I couldn't stop and say,
"Sorry, guys,
I'm just really pregnant now."
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't want to detract
from the nominees, you know?
It wasn't about me
being pregnant in that second.
-Well, it's interesting
because I was watching.
And I did not put
the two together.
-Well, thank you for that.
-And I had a moment,
though of --
-My husband did. He was there.
And he was concerned.
"'Cause I've seen that
happen to you
sometimes when you go up
and down our stairs."
You know, but --
[ Laughter ]
-I wasn't concerned.
I just thought, "Wow, Claire is
so excited about this award."
[ Laughter ]
"She's so..."
-Well, I was.
-Yeah.
-But, you know, hopefully
excitement translates, you know,
in a slightly different way.
-Do you think that
your shortness of breath then
was exacerbated by the fact that
you then had to
speak on television?
-Maybe they had something to do
with each other.
But, like, I've spoken
on television before.
-Right, sure.
-Like, for a few years now.
-Yeah.
-So I think pregnancy
was the thing.
-That was the main thing? Yeah.
-But, yeah, so, anyway.
-Anyway.
-There are humbling moments.
-Well, I also think that would
be a nice thing
to tie back for your child
years from now,
that you could show them exactly
what they did to you.
-What this person has cost me.
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah. The list is long.
-Already. Not been born yet.
-But just for you to be able
to be like,
"Don't make me show you
the Tonys again!"
[ Laughter ]
"Go to your room!"
You have a 5-year-old.
-I do.
-What is his reaction so far to
the idea of an oncoming sibling?
-He's pretty --
I think he's keen.
I mean,
he's mostly enthusiastic.
I mean, when we first told him
I was pregnant,
he said,
"That took a long time, Mom."
[ Laughter ]
"That took a lot of days."
And I was like, "Okay.
Yeah, we've been working on it."
But -- So, yeah, so I guess
he was into it.
But then there was, like,
a little wobble.
And then he was worried
that I was going to love
the baby more than him.
And then anybody who walked
through the door, I was --
I loved more than him, you know.
But he seems to have gotten
through that, too.
And now he hugs my belly.
-That's really great.
-And it's sweet.
But I think it's going to go
up and down.
-Yeah.
-How's your baby
with number two?
-Well, it's a difference in age.
Yours is five now.
-Five, yeah. He's like a person.
-The 2-year-old doesn't --
you know, I don't think he quite
understands jealousy yet.
-Okay.
-As an emotion.
But I think it's coming.
-Yeah.
-But mostly, he just thinks --
he treats the 2-month-old
like a joke.
Every time you say, "Look, it's
your baby," he's like...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. I mean it kind of is.
-Yeah.
-They're useless
for a really long time.
-And the second one
is really useless.
-Really useless. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-Because the first one, at
least, is interesting in the way
like watching "Planet Earth"
is interesting.
-Right, right, right.
-You're like, "Oh, wow, they do
this and they do that."
But now you're like, "I don't
want to watch that episode of
'Planet Earth' again."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So he's great,
but you kind of are --
I still feel like
it's a preview to a movie
I eventually will want to see.
-Right. Okay.
-Yeah.
-Well, I'm prepared.
-Yeah, good.
So, this movie is
adapted from a play
that I saw back in New York
when it was here.
And it's about parents
trying to get,
for those who couldn't tell from
the clip, their kid into school.
Tell us a little more about it.
-Yeah, I mean, it's parents are
trying to get
their 4 1/2-year-old kid
into school.
This 4 1/2-year-old kid happens
to love wearing dresses
and is sort of obsessed with
all things princess.
And it's becoming clear that
maybe he's not conforming
to these strict gender norms.
He's gender fluid, expansive.
The language is intense
right now.
But yeah, so, and so they have
a friend who is an educator,
and as they're applying to
schools, suggests that maybe
they make more of this fact
rather than less.
And suddenly they're just
thinking of him
in these different terms
and they're -- I don't know.
They become kind of anxious
that he's going to be
labeled by society.
And it's really called
"A Kid like Jake"
but the emphasis isn't so much
on the kid.
It's really the parents
and just this crisis
that they're kind of --
they spiral into.
But ultimately, I mean, it's
really just kind of a portrait
of a marriage and a family.
And it's about parents just
trying to figure out
the best way to understand
who their child is
and help them navigate their way
through the world.
So I think in some ways
it's really specific
and it's this very topical idea
of gender identity and politics.
But it's also just about, you
know, releasing your children
into the world and trusting that
they're going to be fine.